HE ALSO WRITES BOOKS IN HIS
SPARE TIME.
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
AND THEY'RE ILLUSTRATED BOOKS
THEY WERE FUN TO READ.
THEY WERE NOT JUST TEXT.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF COOL PICTURES
IN THEM.
SO YOU'RE IN FOR A REAL TREAT.
[OFF MICHAEL RAMIREZ]
BRACK
...
THANK YOU, COLLEAN, AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW I CAME TO BE NUMBER TWO
TWO.
, I GUESS I WAS JUST THE LAST
PERSON STANDING.
IT'S REALLY A PLEASURE FOR ME TO
FIRST OF ALL, HAPPY VALENTINE'S
DAY.
>> SPEAKER: HAPPY VALENTINE'S
DAY TO YOU.
AND I SEE A FEW PEOPLE IN RED.
I TRY TO
MY LITTLE BIT FOR THE
TIE.
IT'S MY PLEASURE ON BEHALF OF
OUR LIBRARIAN OF CONGRESS, DR.
DR. CARLA HAYDEN TO, WELCOME YOU
TO THE LIBRARY, AND I WISH DR.
DR. HAYDEN WAS WITH US TODAY.
SHE HAS STEP THROAT SO DR.
DR. HAYDEN F YOU'RE WATCHING
BECAUSE WE'RE LIVE STREAMOG
YOUTUBE RIGHT NOW, WE WANT YOU
TO GET BETTER.
YOU NEED TO COME BACK AS SOON AS
NUMBER TWO IS HAVING A FEW
PROBLEMS TODAY.
SO THIS IS GREAT.
WE HAVE A WONDERFUL PROGRAM
PLANNED FOR YOU TODAY AND WE'RE
DOING IT WITH ONE OF OUR LONG-
LONG-TIME PARTNERS, "EVERYBODY
WINS D.C." A PROGRAM I'VE KNOWN
ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME AND REALLY
ADMIRE.
THIS IS PART OF THEIR CAREER,
WHERE THEY SELECT A PARTNER, AND
PROVIDE EVERYONE WITH A FREE
BOOK.
I WANT TO TAKE JUST A MOMENT TO
THANK OUR CO-SPONSOR],EVERYBODY
WINS AND I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MOLLY KEYS, THEIR NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
MOLLY.
[APPLAUSE]
.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU, I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE "EVERYBODY
WINS" TO NEW HEIGHTS.
WE'RE JUST DELIGHTED YOU'RE HERE
HERE.
THANKS  TO "EVERYBODY WINS," YOU
ALL ARE GOING TO GET A COPY OF
THE NATIONAL BOOK AWARD-WINNING
MARCH
THE THIRD IT'S A GRAPHIC
NOVEL BY CONGRESSMAN LEWIS, AND
HIS DIGITAL DIRECTOR AND POLICY
ADVISER
ANDREW AYDIN.
SO TOGETHER, THEY HAVE WRITTEN A
ALSO WITH US TODAY, AND THIS IS
A REAL TREAT, FROM WAMURADIO IS
LONG-TIME TALK SHOW HOST KOJO
NNAMDI
KOJO
NNAMDI.
[APPLAUSE].
YES.
WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE
HIM HERE TODAY, TAKING TIME-OUT
OF HIS VERY BUSY SCHEDULE AND HE
IS GOING TO MODERATE OUR
QUESTION AND ANSWER PERIOD,
WHICH IS WHEN YOU ALL WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS.
THE PROGRAM IS BEING RECORDED SO
BEFORE YOU ASK YOUR QUESTION.
NOW I WANT TO GO OFF SCRIPT FOR
JUST TWO MINUTES.
THE FIRST THING IS, I JUST SAW
THE WONDERFUL PBS DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT THE LIFE OF CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS.
IT'S REALLY UNBELIEVABLE.  ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HE TALKS
ABOUT IN THE DOCUMENTARY IS THE
GREAT CIVIL RIGHTS ICON ROSA
PARKS.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE, THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS HAS THE ROSA
AND THEY'RE ALL ONLINE.
CAN YOU GO TO OUR WEBSITE LOC
LOC.GOV AND YOU CAN GET ALL OF,
YOU CAN SEE ALL OF ROSA PARKS'S
PAPERS AND THEY ARE AMAZING.
THE SECOND THING I WANT TO SAY
IS THAT I WAS IN ORLANDO IN JUNE
WHEN CONGRESSMAN LEWIS SPOKE AT
A MEMORIAL SERVICE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF THOSE KILLED IN THE
NIGHT CLUB IN ORLANDO AND
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS, I HAVE TO
TELL YOU, IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
HEARD AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOU DO AND I'M JUST
REALLY GRATEFUL.
SO WITH THAT, I'M GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO KOJO, AND HAVE A
WONDERFUL TIME AND THANK YOU
MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
.
KOJO NNAMDI:  THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING.
THE THIRD INSTALLMENT IN THE
MARCH TRILOGY WRITTEN BY
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS AND
ANDREW AYDIN, HAS WON A LOT OF
AWARDS.
NATIONAL BOOK AWARD FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE'S LITERATURE, THE CORETTA
F.FIBERT INFORMATIONAL AWARD.
THETHE THE WALTER DEAN MEYERS
AWARD
FOR OUTSTANDING CHILDRENS
LITERATURE, YOUNGS DEALT
CATEGORY AND THAT, JUST TO NAME
A FEW.
IT'S A BEST-SELLER THAT HAS
HELPED TO FURTHER BREAK DOWN THE
BARRIERS
AND SO I AM DELIGHTED
TO TALK TO THE CONGRESSMAN AND
ANDREW AYDIN TODAY TO, TALK
ABOUT IT.
COULD YOU PLEASE WELCOME
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS.
[APPLAUSE]
.
AND ANDREW AYDIN.
[APPLAUSE]
.
CONGRESSMAN I'LL START WITH YOU.
IN TALKING ABOUT IT, WITH
STUDENTS, LIBRARIANS AND
JOURNALISTS, YOU GAVE A REALLY
MOVING SPEECH IN ACCEPTING THE
NATIONAL BOOK AWARD LATE LAST
YEAR.
WHAT DOES THE RECOGNITION OF
THIS WORK RECEIVED MEAN TO YOU.
?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  FIRST OF ALL
ALL, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU,
BROTHER.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE GOOD AND
GREAT GRATE THINGS THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO DO.
IT'S GOOD TO BE HERE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS, TO SEE ALL
OF YOU BEAUTIFUL, HANDSOME,
YOUNG PEOPLE.
YOU LOOK SO WONDERFUL.
YOU LOOK SO SMART
.
SPEAK ABOUT THIS BOOK, READ THE
BOOK.
TURN THE PAGES, AND JOINING IN
THE IMAGES, IT TAKES ME BACK TO
ANOTHER PART OF MY LIFE.
IN READING MARCH BOOK 1, BOOK 2,
ALABAMA, I THOUGHT IT WAS A
PLACE CALLED TROY.
SO I WILL RECEIVE THE HONOR
ALONE -- I WON'T RECEIVE THE --
I WILL RECEIVE THE
HONOR WITHDY.
IT TOOK ME BACK
TO RURAL ALABAMA
IN 1956, WHEN I WAS 15 YEARS OLD
OLD, WITH MY BROTHERS  AND
COUSINS, WE WENT TO A LITTLE
LIBRARY TO TRY TO GET A LIBRARY
CARD AND CHECK OUT SOME BOOK.
WE WERE TOLD BY THE THE
LIBRARIAN
WAS FOR WHITES ONLY AND NOT FOR
COLORS.
AND THEN GO BACK TO THE
LIBRARIAN TO MANY, MANY YEARS.
BY THIS TIME, I'M IN CONGRESS
FOR A BOOK SIGNING.
SO HUNDREDS OF BLACKS  AND WHITE
CITIZENS SHOWED UP AND AFTER THE
BOOK SIGNING, AFTER WE HAD SOME
REFRESHMENTS, AND TO WORK WITH
ANDREW, WHO IS SO GIFTED AND SO
SMART
AND NATE POW WEL, IT WELIT HAS
BEEN A WORK OF LOVE.  AND TO SEE
TO GET THE BOOK, TO GET THE BOOK
SIGNED AND TO TAKE A SEAT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE FLOOR, AT A TABLE,
A DESK AND READ THE BOOK, AND AS
AS
I TRAVEL AROUND AMERICA,
DIFFERENT PLACES, PEOPLE COME UP
SIGNED FOR MY
BROTHERS, ANEW NIECES, ANEW
NEPHEWS, WHICH I THINK IS A GOOD
THING.
WE ALL SHOULD READ.
BOOKS ARE POWERFUL.
THEY CAN TAKE US PLACES THAT WE
DARE TO GO.
KOJO NNAMDI:  I'M GLAD YOU
FINALLY GOT YOUR LIBRARY CARD.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE THIRD BOOK
IN THE SERIES.
LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHY THIS PROJECT TOOK THE SHAPE
IT DID AND THE GRAPHIC NOVEL.
IT HAS TIE TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
NEWMENT.
WHEN DID YOU FIRST ENCOUNTER A
COMIC THAT SPOKE TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  IN LATE 1957
BOOK CALLED MARTIN LUTHER KING,
JR.  AND THE MONTGOMERY STORY.
IT SOLD FOR 10-CENTS AND ANDREW
WILL TELL YOU, THROUGH HIS
RESEARCH, HE DISCOVERED THAT DR.
KING HAD EDITED THIS BOOK.
THIS BOOK BECAME LIKE A ROAD MAP
FOR THOSE OF US WHO GOT INVOLVED
IN THE AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
IT TOLD THE STORY OF MONTGOMERY.
IT SPOKE ABOUT THE WAY OF PEACE,
OF NONVIOLENCE, HOW PEOPLE
ORGANIZE, HOW PEOPLE WORKED,
SHARED
RISE AND CAUSE, RODE IN
SEGREGATED BUSES IN MONTH
GENTLEMAN G.O.P. RYAND
MONTGOMERYIES DURING THE 50'S,
BLACK AND WHITE PEOPLE COULDN'T
BE SEATED TOGETHER ON A CITY BUS
BUS.
EVEN HERE IN WASHINGTON D.C. IN
1961, DURING THE FREEDOM RISE,
BLACK PEOPLE AND WHITE PEOPLE
COULDN'T BE SEATED TOGETHER,
LEAVING WASHINGTON, TO TRAVEL
THROUGH VIRGINIA, GA G ALABAMA,
MISS.
SO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION,
WHETHER THE BUSES HAD BEEN A
MEANS OF CARRYING THE STORY OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
YOU HAD TO BRING DOWN THOSE
SIGNS.
WHITE MEP, COLORED MEN.
WHITE WOMEN, COLORED WOMEN.
TODAY, GROWING UP, YOU WON'T SEE
THOSE BUS ON -- YOU WON'T SEE
THOSE
SIGNS  ON A BUS TODAY, THE ONLY
WAY YOU WOULD SEE SEE THOSE
SIGNS TODAY IS IN A BOOK, A
MUSEUM OR IN A VIDEO THEY'RE
GONE AND IT'S MY HOPE THEY WILL
NEVER EVER RETURN.
KOJO NNAMDI:  DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE CONGRESSMAN ENCOUNTERED
MARTIN LUTHER KING WHEN HE WAS
JUST 17 YEARS OLD, YOU STILL HAD
CONVINCING YOUR COLLEAGUES AND
OKAY THE CONGRESSMAN HIMSELF TO
WRITE A GRAPHIC NOVEL.
WHY DID YOU THINK THIS WAS THE
RIGHT FORMAT FOR THIS PROJECT??
>> I GREW UP IN ATLANTA, THE
CONGRESSMAN HAS BEEN THE
CONGRESSMAN SINCE I WAS THREE
YEARS OLD.
YOU WENT TO PUBLIC SCHOOL AND I
FELT HEARD THE STORY OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
I HEARD IT IN DOCUMENTARIES, IN
BOOK, I HEARD PEOPLE TELL THE
STORY.
BUT TO ME, I HAD GROWNUP READING
COMICS.  IT'S SORT OF MY
SALVATION.
MY REFUGE.
MY FATHER LEFT WHEN I WAS FOUR,
FIVE YEARS OLD AND IT WAS WHERE
I TURNED.
I WANTED STORIES OF HEROS WHO
WANTED JUSTICE BECAUSE IT WAS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO
.
[MICROPHONE FOOD AND WATER BACK]
>> SPEAKER: SHOULD I BEAT BOX
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT SUMMER, BARACK OBAMA IS
SWEEPING THROUGHOUT DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARIES.
PEOPLE IN POLITICS WERE RE
REEVALUATING THE WAY THEY COULD
COMMUNICATE.
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE, WHETHER IT
WAS THE INTERNET, THE VISUAL
LITERACY THAT COMES WITH THAT.
OR HOW WE TALK TO PEOPLE.
WHAT WE'RE WILLING TO TALK ABOUT
ABOUT.
SO AS IT CAME DOWN TO THE END OF
ABOUT MARTIN LUTHER KING AND THE
MONTH GENTLEMAN G.O.P. FREE
STORY.
HERE, I HAD SPENT THE WHOLE
SUMMER TELLING JOHN LEWIS
TELLING STORIES OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE, WHICH WAS SO MUCH
DIFFERENT NOT THAT STORY I HAD
ALWAYS BEEN TOLD.
AT THE SAME TIME.
THE CONGRESSMAN WAS TELLING ME
THAT HE READ A COMIC BOOK WHEN
HE THOUGHT ABOUT JOINING THE
MOVEMENT.
THE 24-YEAR-OLD NERD JUST KIND
OF EXPLODE, AND IT FELT LIKE IT
WAS OKAY TO BE ME.
MAYBE IT WAS ALL THE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO PUT THEM DOWN WHO
WERE WRONG.
SO WHEN I STARTED THINKING, YOU
KNOW, THERE SHOULD BE A COMIC
BOOK ABOUT JOHN LEWIS'S LIFE, IT
SUMMER, WHAT I HAD WITNESSED
FIRSTHAND.  AND HEARING JOHN
LEWIS TELL THE STORY, SEEING HIM
ACT IT OUT, SEEING HIM IN FRONT
OF YOU, THAT WAS A BIG PART OF
IT FOR ME, SO TRYING TO FIND A
WAY TO CAPTURE THAT EXPERIENCE
AND PUT IT DOWN ON PAPER, WORLDS
ALONE COULD NOT DO IT THE
JUSTICE THAT IT NEEDED.
KOJO NNAMDI UPON:  WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THE SHIFT OF PERCEPTION
THAT THE
GRAPHIC
NOVEL.
>> SPEAKER: I THINK "MARCH" IS
PUTTING IT BACK TOGETHER
STRONGER THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK WE SET OUT TO DO
THAT, PER SE.
WE SET OUT TO TELL JOHN LEWIS'S
STORY, TO REACH IT MORE PEOPLE
THAN HAD EVER BEEN REACHED BY
THIS STORY.
COMICS ARE COMING OF AGE BECAUSE
OF THE INTERNET.
LIKE ALL OF YA'LL, YA'LL ARE
DYNEL TILL NATIVES.
YOU GREW UP ON THE INTERNET.
YOU COMMUNICATE THROUGH MEANS.
YOU HAVE BOLD CONVERSATIONS
WITH SUCCESS KIDS, AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO YEAH.
AND SO FOR THIS GENERATION.
COMIC SYSTEM THEIR NATURAL
LANGUAGE.  IT IS GRAPHIC
NARRATIVE.
IT IS SEQUENTIAL STORY TELLING.
IT'S SIMPLY HOW THIS GENERATION
SPEAKS TO EACH OTHER.
AND IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME,
WHAT WE'RE MOST FORTUNATE ABOUT
IS IT'S JOHN LEWIS'S STORY THAT
BROKE DOWN THAT BARRIER, IT WAS
RIGHT THERE WHEN IT NEEDED TO BE
AS OPPOSED TO, WE COULD ALL BE
CELEBRATED
CELEBRATING THE, I DON'T KNOW,
THE GREAT PUPPY WARS OR
SOMETHING, THAT REALLY WOULDN'T
RESIDE NATE THIS WITH THE WAY
JOHN LEWIS'STORY DOES.
SO I THINK IT WAS A COMBINATION
OF BEING JUST A LITTLE BIT AHEAD
OF OUR TIME AND BEING AT THE
RIGHT PLACE FOR THIS GENERATION,
KOJO NNAMDI:  CONGRESSMAN LEWIS
D IT TAKE A LOT OF CONVINCING TO
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  LIKE ANDREW
SAID, IT TOOK A LITTLE TIME B.
HE DIDN'T GIVE UP.
HE JUST SAID CONGRESSMAN, JUST
WRITE A COMIC BOOK.  I SAID OH.
MAYBE.
CAME BACK AGAIN
CAME BACK AGAIN.
AND THE REST IS HISTORY.
KOJO NNAMDI:  INDEED AIR, MARK
OF HISTORY.
THIS TRAILOLOGY BEGAN ON THE EVE
INAUGURATION.
A REFLECTION OF THE WORK YOU
WERE DOING ON CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
AND ARE WE IN A PERIOD NOW WHERE
WE'RE SEEING THAT THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  L
... L I THINK
WE ARE FOR A MEETING WE ARE
ENTERING IN DISCUSSION.
BUT I THINK IN AMERICA TODAY,
RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE SAYING
WHERE ARE WE GOING AS A NATION
AND AS A PEOPLE?
ARE WE GOING BACKWARD?
ARE WE GOING TO STAND STILL OR
ARE WE GOING TO GO FORWARD?
I THINK "MARCH" TELLS US ALL
THAT, WE HAVE COME A DISTANCE,
WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS,
BUT THERE ARE FORCING THAT WANT
TO SLOW US DOWN OR TAKE US BACK.
AND WE WOULD LIKE FOR PEOPLE TO
BE HOPEFUL, TO BE OPTIMISTIC AND
TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE ONE
PEOPLE.
THAT IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER
WE ARE BLACK, WHITE, LATINO,
ASIAN-AMERICAN OR NATIVE-
NATIVE-AMERICAN.
WE ALL LIVE IN THE SAME HOUSE
WORLD FEDERATION HOUSE.
A. PHILIP RANDOLPH WE SPEAK
ABOUT BECAUSE HE WAS THE MAN
THAT CALLED TOGETHER THE MARCH
ON WALK WALK AND HE USED  TO SAY
FROM TIME TO TIME MAYBE OUR FORE
FOREMOTHERS  AND FOREFATHERS ALL
DIFFERENT SHIPS.
WE'RE ALL IN THE SAME BOAT NOW.
WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR EACH
OTHER AND HELP EACH OTHER.
AND DR. KING SAID ON ONE
OCCASION, AND HE SAID IT SO
BEAUTIFULLY, THAT WE MUST LEARN
TO LIVE TOGETHER
AS ONE FAMILY,
AS ONE PEOPLE.
IF NOT, WE WOULD PERISH AS FOOLS
FOOLS.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE MESSAGE
THAT WE TRY TO CONVEY IN MARCH
THAT IT'S BETTER TO LOVE
IT'S
BETTER TO ABIDE BY THE
PRINCIPLES AND THE PHILOSOPHY OF
NONVIOLENCE AND NEVER HATE, FOR
HATE IS TOO HEAVY A BURDEN TO
BEAR
.
KOJO NNAMDI:  A. PHILIP RANDOLPH
HE CALLED THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON TOGETHER IN 1963.
ANDREW AYDIN, AS YOU WERE GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WITH THE
KONGMAN T GAVE YOU NOT ONLY A
PERSPECTIVE ON HIS LIFE, BUT DID
PERSPECTIVE ON HISTORY, THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO BETTER INTERPRET
THE PRESENT?
ANDREW AYDIN:  ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN WE FIRST DEBUTED BOOK 1, WE
WENT TO SAN DIEGO COMICON, WHICH
IS MORE OF MY PEOPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
AND SO WE START OFF, YOU GIVE A
LITTLE SPEECH ABOUT
YOU KNOW,
THIS IS WHAT MY BOOK IS CALLED.
I ASKED HAVE ANY OF YOU EVER
WATCHED "BATTLESTAR GALACTICA"
ALMOST EVERY PERSON'S HAND WENT
UP IN THE ROOM.
I SAID YOU'LL REMEMBER.  ALL OF
THIS HAS HAPPENED BEFORE AND ALL
.
THIS IS BEFORE FERGUSON.
BEFORE ERIC GARNER, BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
THIS WAS AT A TIME THAT I THINK
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE QUIET FOR A KYLE.
BUTT MORE YOU UNDERSTAND ABOUT
JOHN LEWIS'S STORY AND HOW MANY
OF OUR POLITICS TODAY ARE A
DIRECT RESULT FROM FORCES TRYING
TO OPPOSE THE PROGRESS THAT HE
MADE, THE MORE IT SEEMED LIKE AN
AND AT THE SAME TIME, I HOPE WE
CONVEYED THE OPTIMISM THAT THE
ACTIVISTS TODAY NEED, THAT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE, THEY NEED.
I OFTEN ASK THE QUESTION OR POSE
IT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE SCLC STILL
STILL, WE HAVE THE N.A.A.C.P.
STILL.
WE HAVE THE URBAN LEAGUE STILL.
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE IS A STUDENT
NONVIOLENCE COORDINATING
COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN ORGANIZATION,
DEDICATED TO YOUNG PEOPLE OF
DIRECT ACTION, THAT IS
COMPLETELY STAFFED AND ORGANIZE
ORGANIZED
AND RUN BY YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT IN
THAT SORT OF CONTEXT TODAY,
HISTORY IS YOUR GUIDE.
KOJO NNAMDI:  WHAT STOOD OUT TO
YOU THAT MAYBE YOU DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT BEFORE?
MANY PEOPLE I KNOW ARE FROM THE
CARIBBEAN.
WHAT I (INAUDIBLE) NAMED ALEX
ALEXER
AND LUGEY, TURNED OUT WAS FROM
ANTERGIA WEST INDIES
FROMMAN ANTIGA WEST INDIES.
DID YOU HAVE THOSE KINDS OF
EXPERIENCES  IN WHO STOOD OUT TO
YOU, ANDREW THAT YOU DONE KNOW
ABOUT BEFORE?
ANDREW AYDIN:  THERE ARE SO MANY
OF THEM N. NASHVILLE, I HAD NO
IDEA IDEA ABOUT WILL CAMPBELL
ORACLEY SMITH.
JEN LAWSON, OFF THE BAT, I'VE
HEARD ABOUT HIM AND THE
CONGRESSMAN HAS SPOKEN ABOUT HIM
HIM, BUT THE EXTENT OF REVEREND
LAWSON'S ROLE IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT HAS BEEN LOST
AND I HOPE WE RESURRECTED HIS
CONTRIBUTION.
IT IS SO POWERFUL.
HE MAY BE THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
ON THE MOVEMENT BEHIND MARTIN
LUTHER KING
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T
REQUEST WHEN YOU PEOPLE DO THAT
TODAY, IT'S HARD NOT TO SEE IF
THEY WALK IN THE LEGACY OF MR.
MR. THURMAN.
I CAME TO APPRECIATE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A. PHILIP
RANDOLPH.
THREATENED THE FIRST MARCH ON
WASHINGTON IN 1941 AND MADE F FD
R
BLINK AND DESEGREGATE PARTS OF
THE INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX Q. IT WAS
2'S RESEARCH PERIOD, I READ AN
INTERVIEW, FROM RUSTON AND ASKED
HE SAID, THERE WAS THIS MOMENT
AT THE END OF THE MARCH ON WALK
WALK.
HE CAME BACK TO THE OFFICE AND
HE SAW A. PHILIP RANDOLPH
LOOKING AT HIS SIGN AND HE START
STARTED TEASING HIM.
PIECE OF TRASH GARBAGE IS
COMPLETELY CLEANED UP.
THINKING IT WAS A CELEBRATORY
MOMENT.  AND RANDOLPH HAD TEARS
STREAMING DOWN HIS FACE.  AND HE
YOU.
HE SAID THAT WAS THE MOST MEAN
MEANINGFUL MOMENT OF HIS LIFE
AND HERE IT IS, BURPYIED IN AY
BURP BURIED IN A
TEXT BOOK SOMEWHERE.
WHAT A PRIVILEDGE.
A THANK YOU THAT WAS LONG, LONG
OVER DUE.
KOJO NNAMDI:  TO THE YOUNG
PEOPLE HERE, WHEN YOU PASS
THROUGH UNION STATION, THERE'S A
IS THIS UNBELIEVABLE MAN WHO WAS
BORN IN JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA,
MOVED TO NEW YORK CITY, BECAME A
THE ABILITY TO ORGANIZE AND MOVE
PEOPLE AND INFLUENCE AS ANDREW
STATED.
IT WAS A. PHILIP RANDOLPH WHO
CALLED THAT MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT KENNEDY.
WE HAD THE FIST MEETING TO
DISCUSS THE POSSIBILITY OF A
MARCH ON WASHINGTON.
YOU SPEAK ABOUT [INDISCERNIBLE]
LUBY.
AN AMAZING LAWYER.
JUST AN UNBELIEVABLE
HUMAN
BEINGS.
WE WERE SITTING IN, MARCHING AS
STUDENTS, HIS HOME WAS BOMBED
EARLY ONE MORNING
.
IT DESTROYED HIS HOUSE.
HIS WIFE WAS KNOCKED OUT OF HER
BED
.
THE CLAN TRIED KILL HIM AND
DESTROY.
WE MADE A DECISION TO MARCH WHEN
LIKE 6:30 IN THE MORNING.
WE SENT A TELEGRAM TO THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF NASHVILLE, SAYING
IN EFFECT
, MR. MAYOR, BE AT
STEPS OF CITY HALL AT NOON.
BY NOON,.
ANDREW AYDIN:  HIGH NOON.
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  THAT'S
RIGHT., ANDREW.
HIGH NOON.  AND WE HAD THOUSANDS
NOTWITHSTANDINGS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
PEOPLE, BLACK, WHITE, HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS, CONGRESS
STUDENTS, PARENTS, TEACHERS,
COLLEGE PROFESSIONALS AND THE
MAYOR SAID YES, I FAVOR
DESEGREGATION
.
KOJO NNAMDI:  THERE'S SO MUCH
HISTORY PACKED IN THESE TRAIL
TRAILOLOGYIES.
SO MANY NAME THAT IS JUMP OUTOUT
AT YOU, ELA BAKER, JAMES FOREMAN
FOREMAN, BOB MOSES.
FANNY LOU HAMER.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ANY ONE
OF THOSE WHO
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
ANDREW AYDIN:  I'D ABOUT WITH EL
ELA BAKER RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
SHE WAS THE MOTHER OF THE MOVE
MOVEMENT.
AND IT'S SO PIVOTAL IN A WAY,
IT'S NOT FULLY UNDERSTOOD TODAY
AND I HOPE WE CONVEYED THAT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
SHE'S ONE OF THOSE
CHARACTERISTICS THAT LIVES YOU
WITH THROUGH ALL THE BOOKS.
SHE WAS THERE AT FOUNDING OF SNI
SNICC AND SHE WAS SHE WAS A
KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT THEIR POLITIC
POLITICAL CONVENTION.
SHE WAS SO IMPORTANT AND I THINK
ONE OF THE GREAT TRAGEDIES OF
THE HISTORY THAT'S BEEN TOLD
THUS FAR IS WOMEN'S ROLES DURING
THE MOVEMENT HAVE BEEN MARGINAL
MARGINALIZEED AND I THINK FOR US
,
IT WAS SO IMPORTANT TO CORRECT
THAT, TO SHOW
EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED, THEY WERE OFTEN SO
THEY DIDN'T PUSH TO BE THE ONE
TO BE IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
THEY PUSHED TO BE THE ONE WHO
DID THE WORK, WHO WHO ACHIEVED
THE HARDEST PART.
KOJO NNAMDI:  WHEN I FIRST CAME
TO WASHINGTON.
AMONG MY MONTH ORS ARE THOSE WHO
I KNEW ALL OF THEIR NAMES,
DIDN'T QUITE KNOW THE DETAILS OF
THE TRILL SCREE HELP MEAD
UNDERSTAND.
WHY THEY REVERED BOB MOWSAN SO
MUCH.
BUT YOU TWO WORKED  WITH NATE
POWERS.
HIS IMAGES ARE VIVID AND
SOMETIMES DIFFICULT TO LOOK AT.
WAS IT DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO LOOK
BACK AT THOSE.
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  YES AND IT'S
PICK UP THIS BOOK.
THIS IS BOOK 3.
BOOK 1 AND BOOK 2 AND SEE SOME
OF THE IMAGES.
SOMETIMES I TEAR AND SOMETIMES I
CRY.
THERE'S AN ILLUSTRATION OF THIS
BOOK, DEPICTING ME MARCHING AND
I LOVE IT BECAUSE, I GUESS AS
YOUNG PEOPLE AND I'M NOT THAT
YOUNG ANYMORE, BUT I DID LOOK SO
[LAUGHTER]
I HAD ALL OF MY HAIR AND I WAS A
ME
WITH MY BACK PACK, BACK IN 1985,
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO BE
ARRESTED AND GO TO JAIL.
SO I BROUGHT A BACK PACK FROM AN
ARMY SURPLUS STORE, OF ALL
PLACES AND I WANTED TO HAVE
SOMETHING TO READ WHILE I WAS
IN
JAIL:  I THOUGHT I WAS REALLY
GOING TO JAIL.
I HAD TWO BOOKS.
I WANTED SOMETHING TO EAT.
I HAD AN APPLE AND AN ORANGE.
I SAID I'M GOING TO BE IN JAIL
WITH MY FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUESES
COLLEAGUESES.
I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO BRUSH MY
TEETH.
SO I HAD TOOTHPASTE, A
TOOTHBRUSH.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BOOK 3 AND TURN
TOLD YOU THIS.
I LOVE THAT IMAGE OF THIS STRONG
STRONG, YOUNG, JOHN LEWIS
GETTING READY TO WALK ACROSS
THAT BRIDGE
.
KOJO NNAMDI:  AN APPLE AND AN
ORANGE.
YOU KNOW, READING THESE BOOKS,
ONE DISCOVERS THAT YOU OFTEN
WENT AGAINST THE GRAIN OF WHAT
OTHERS IN THE MOVEMENT MOVEMENT
WERE
DOING, SKIPPING THE SIGNING
CEREMONY FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT.
KEEPING THE PROTEST GOING WHEN
THE SO-CALLED [INDISCERNIBLE]
ASKED YOU NOT TO.
GOING AHEAD WITH THE
AFOREMENTIONED SELMA TO
MONTGOMERY MARV, WHEN OTHERS
WERE AGAINST IT.
AND YOU TALK A LOT ABOUT THIS
IDEA OF GOOD TROUBLE, ABOUT
STANDING UP FOR WHAT'S RIGHT,
EVEN WHEN IT'S NOT POPULAR.
WHEN IT'S NOT EASY.
WHERE DID YOU GET THAT STRENGTH
FROM?
WHAT DO YOU WANT THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO KNOW ABOUT THE NOTION
OF GOOD TROUBLE IF MAYBE JUST AS
YOU'RE GETTING INTO THE GOOD
KIND OF TROUBLE AND NOT THE BAD
KIND?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  L IT'S VERY
SIMPLE.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP IN A
LITTLE TOWN OF TROY, MONTGOMERY.
TROY IS ABOUT 10 MILES FROM
WHERE I GREW UP.
YOU GO DOWNTOWN TROY, YOU SEE
THE SIGNS THAT SAY WHITE AND
COLORED.
GO TO A MOVIE ON A SATURDAY
AFTERNOON.
ALL OF US LOOK LIKE CHILDREN.
HAD TO GO UPSTAIRS TO THE
BALCONY AND ALL THE WHITE
CHILDREN WERE DOWNSTAIRS.
I WOULD COME HOME AND ASK MY
MOTHER, MY FATHER, MY
GRANDPARENTS.
WHY.
THAT'S THE WAY IT IS.
DON'T GET IN TROUBLE.
BUT I HEARD OF ROSA PARKS WHEN I
AND I MET ROSA PARKS WHEN I WAS
17.
I HEARD OF DR. KING WHEN I WAS
15 YEARS OLD, AND I MET HIM WHEN
IT CHANGED MY MIND SO I WAS
INSPIRED TO GET INTO WHAT I CALL
CALL, GOOD TROUBLE.
NECESSARY TROUBLE AND I'VE BEEN
GETTING IN TROUBLE EVER SINCE.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT RIGHT, NOT FAIR NOT JUST,
YOU HAVE AN ENGAGES TO SAY --
YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO SAY SOMETHING TO,
DO SOMETHING.
YOU CANNOT AFFORD TO BE SILENT.
IF YOU THINK
YOU ARE BEING MIS
MISTREATED, YOU HAVE TO RESIST
AND SAY, THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT JUST
FOR THE STUDENTS
IN THIS ROOM WORKS LIVE IN THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA, A CITY
THAT HAS.
KOJO NNAMDI:  RESIDENTS OF WHOM,
MANY WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS AS A
STATE, THESE YOUNG PEOPLE MAY
ONE DAY, DECIDE TO BE ACTIVE NOW
NOW, AND EVEN MORE SO REQUEST
THEY REACH VOTING AGE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE VERY
FUNDAMENT QUESTION THAT IS
PERSIST?
AROUND THE ISSUE OF VOTING
RIGHTS, NOT JUST AROUND THE
DISTRICT, BUT IN A LOT OF
JURISDICTION IN THE UNITED
STATES WHEN, IT COMES  TO
ADEQUATE VOTER REPRESENTATION?
VOTING RIGHTS ACT WAS PASSED  IN
ANDREW AYDIN:  YEAH, I'M A D.C.
RESIDENT.
I THINK IT'S LONG OVER DUE THAT
WE HAVE FULL REPRESENTATION IN
CONGRESS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE CAN
LIVE IN THE CITY AND PAY TAXES
IN THE CITY AND IT SEEMS SO
OFTEN THAT THE OPPONENTS OF
VOTING RIGHTS ARE ALSO THE
PEOPLE WHO DECLARE THEIR RIGHTS,
BASED ON HOW MUCH TAXES WE PAY
AND YET, HERE WE ARE IN THE
DISTRICT AND WE PAY QUITE A
LITTLE BIT.
AND WE WENT HAVE FULL REPRESENT
REPRESENTATION.
I THINK FOR CROWNING PEOPLE IN
PARTICULAR, IT'S A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE.
I'M JUST SAYING.
DON'T TELL YOUR TEACHERS.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT,
VOTING RIGHTS ARE UNDER ATTACK.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, WHETHER
IT IS FICTITIOUS CLAIM THAT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE VOTING
ILLEGALLY, LET'S JUST SAY IT,
THEY'RE NOT.
OR THE ATTEMPTS TO MAKE IT
HARDER AND MORE DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO REGISTER AND VOTE.
FULL DISCLOSURE, I WORKED ON ONE
AND I WAS SHOCKED TO FIND
THAT
ONLY HAS ONE VOTER PROTECTION
TEAMS.  THE OTHER PARTY DOESN'T
NEED THEM.
THEIR VOTERS DON'T HAVE ANY
TROUBLE.
AND THAT WAS PROFOUND TO ME.
THAT WE COULD CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT WAS SO LOPSIDED IN ITS
CERTAINLYIES.
WHEN YOU WORK FOR JOHN LEWIS,
IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL BELIEF THAT
WE WERE ALL CREATEDICALLY AND IN
THE RIGHT TO VOTE AS PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATES IN THE AMERICAN
WHEN YOU WORK AGAINST THAT, YOU
WORK AGAINST WHAT MAKES AMERICA
STRONG AND WHAT HAS BROUGHT
AMERICA TO THE FOREFRONT OF
GLOBAL POWER AND IT MAKES
AMERICA WEAK.
KOJO NNAMDI:  FOR THOSE OF YOU
IN THIS ROOM WHO MAY BE THINK
WHAT YOUR RIGHTS ARE, AND SHOULD
BE.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT SITTING IN
THIS ROOM IS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA.
SO WHEN THIS IS OVER, YOU SHOULD
CONGRESSMAN, WOULD YOU RAISE
YOUR HAND, PLEASE.
[APPLAUSE]
.
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS, WE SEE A LOT
PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO EFFECT CHANGE
BUT THERE ARE THOSE WHO SAY, THE
CURRENT DIRECTION LAX LEADERSHIP
AND COHESION, SOME OF THE THINGS
PEOPLE SAID ABOUT IN 1960, AS I
RECALL.
WHAT IS YOUR HOPE FOR WHAT THESE
BOOKS, AND FOR WHAT YOU CAN
TEACH THIS YOUNG GENERATION OF
ACTIVISTS AND PROTESTING.
>> SPEAKER: IT IS MY HOPE THESE
BOOKS WOULD INSPIRE ANOTHER
GENERATION, BUT ESPECIALLY YOUNG
LESSONS OF THE MOVEMENT.
WHAT WE DID AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND HOW WE
SUCCEEDED AND TO BE HOPEFUL, TO
BE OPTIMISTIC AND TO NEVER GIVE
UP.
BUT HOLD ON TO YOUR DREAMS ON
.
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  THESE BOOKS
ARE A BLUEPRINT, A ROAD MAP.
I GOT ARRESTED A FEW TIMES.
40 TIMES AND SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
CONGRESS, ANOTHER FIVE TIMES.
MY LAST ARREST, THIS YOUNG MAN,
I LEFT SOME MONEY SOME PLACE, SO
ANDREW AYDIN:  SPOTTED YOU A FEW
DOLLARS.
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  SPOT MEAD A
FEW DOLLARS TO BE RELEASED.
THE LAST ARREST TOOK PLACE A
SHORT DISTANCE FROM HERE, ON
CAPITAL GROUNDS, 200 PEOPLE.
EIGHT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, WHO
WERE TRYING TO GET THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE TO BRING FORTH A
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
IF THEY HAD BROUGHT THE BILL TO
THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE, ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER ON OUR SIDE
WOULD HAVE VOTED FOR IT AND WE
WOULD HAVE HAD ENOUGH MEMBERS
FROM THE OTHER SIDE AND WE WOULD
AND PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA WOULD
HAVE SIGNED IT INTO LAW.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR US TO
HAVE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE,
CHILDREN LIVING IN FEAR THAT
SOMETHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
THEM OR TO THEIR PARENTS OR
GRAND PARENTS.
WHEN THE.CAME AND SPOKE TO A
JOINT SESSION ON CONGRESS, HE
SAID WE ARE ALL IMMIGRANTS.
WE ALL COME FROM SOME OTHER
PLACE
AND THAT WILL PROBABLY BE
THE GREAT DEBATE IN THE DAYS TO
COME.
NONE OF US ARE REALLY FREE AND
ALL OF US ARE FREE.
KOJO NNAMDI:  NOW, IT'S TIME FOR
I KNOW THERE ARE THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE READ ONE, TWO, OR ALL
BOOKS IN THE TRILL SCREE.
NOW IS THE TIME -- IN THE
TRILOGY.
NOW IS THE TIME TO RAISE YOUR
HANDS OTHERWISE I'LL JUST KEEP
TALKING  AND BORE TO YOU TEARS.
OH,.
S  TO A HAND UP FRONT HERE.
STAND UP SO WE CAN SEE YOU.
>> SPEAKER: I DIDN'T DO RESEARCH
AROUND WHEN MARTIN LUTHER KING
WAS BORN OR IS HE OLDER TAN YOU?
KOJO NNAMDI:  WHEN WERE YOU BORN
IN RELATION TO WHEN DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING WAS BORN.
LEWIS:  DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING,
JR. WAS BORN IN 1929.
AND I WAS BORN IN 1940.
SO IN A SENSE, IT WAS LIKE A BIG
I MET HIM WHEN I WAS 18
YEARS OLD.
HE CHANGEED MY LIFE.
ANDREW WILL TELL YOU, HE CALLED
ME THE BOY FROM TROY
.
SOME OF YOU READ WHEN I WAS A
LITTLE BOY, I WANTED TO BE A
MINISTER AND WE USED  TO RAISE
CHICKENS, AND WITH THE HELP OF
MY BROTHERS  AND SISTERS  AND
COUSINS, WE WOULD GATHER ALL OF
OUR CHICKENS TOGETHER IN THE
CHICKEN YARD, LIKE RIGHT HERE IN
THIS ROOM.
AND MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS  AND
YARD AND I WOULD START SPEAKING
OR PREACHING AND WHEN I LOOKED
BACK, SOME OF THESE KICKENS
WOULD BOW THEIR HEADS.  LAWSUIT
SOME OF THE CHICKENS WOULD SHAKE
THEIR HEADS.
THEY NEVER QUITE SAID AMEN.
BUT I'M CONVINCED SOME OF THOSE
CHICKENS CAME TO LISTEN TO ME,
MUCH BETTER THAN SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES LISTEN TO ME TODAY IN
[LAUGHTER]
AND SOME OF THOSE CHICKENS WERE
A LITTLE MORE PRODUCTIVE.
THEY PRODUCED EGGS  AND THEY
WANTED ME TO SELL IT'LL THAT
STORY.
ANDREW AYDIN:  WE HAD TO LEAVE
THOSE LINES OUT OF THE BOOK.
KOJO NNAMDI:  I FOUND THAT TO BE
THE MOST FASCINATING PART OF THE
BOOK.
ME KNEW THE CHICKENS
INDIVIDUALLY.
BY NAME AND AFTER A POINT, HE
DIDN'T LIKE THE FACT THAT THE
CHICKENS HAD TO BE KILLED, IN
ORDER TO BE EATEN.
LEWIS:  I DIDN'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT MY MOTHER AND FATHER WANTED
TO HAVE SOME OF THOSE CHICKENS
FOR A WHEEL AND I GOT -- FOR A
MALE.
I GOT TO KNOW THESE CHICKENS.
I TOLD THEM TO BE QUIET.
NOT TO MAKE NOISE AND FOR THEM
TO LOVE EACH OTHER.
[LAUGHTER]
KOJO NNAMDI:  ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS?
>> ACTUALLY, LAST YEAR, OUR
SCHOOL WENT TO A FIELD TRIP TO A
MEMORIALS, ALL AROUND, ALL
AROUND THE SOUTH AND SO WON'T
PLACES WE ACTUALLY WENT TO WAS
SELMA.  WE WALKED ACROSS THE
BRIDGE THAT YOU WALKED ACROSS ON
ON.
SO COULD YOU TELL US WHAT SOME
OF YOUR EXPERIENCES WERE WHEN
YOU CROSSED THAT BRIDGE?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  IN SELMA,
ALABAMA, PEOPLE OF COLOR COULD
NOT REGISTER TO VOTE BECAUSE OF
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN
.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN LISTER, DOCTORS
DOCTORS, TEACHERS, HOUSEWIVES,
FARMERS WERE TOLD THAT THEY
COULD NOT READ OR WRITE WELL
ENOUGH.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE
(INAUDIBLE) THE NUMBER
OF JELLY BEANS IN A JAR.
ONE DAY, MORE THAN 300 PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS LEFT SCHOOL.
LINE UP AND WENT DOWN TO THE
COURT HOUSE, RECEIVED A COPY OF
THE TEST.
THEY STOOD IN LINE.  THE RENAL
STAR CLOSED THE OFFICE AND THEY
WERE DENIED THE RIGHT TO
REGISTER TO VOTE.
AND FEW DAYS LATER, CELL MARX A
GROUP OF PEOPLE MARCHING, IT WAS
A PROTEST IN A HOME TOWN OF
CORETTA SCOTT KING.
ONE PROTESTER WAS SHOT AND LATER
DIED AT THE LOCAL HOSPITAL IN
SELMA.  THE CAUSE OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIM, WE MADE A
DECISION TO MARCH FROM SELMA TO
MONTGOMERY.
600 OF US, ORDERLY, PEACEFUL, NO
WORD.
THE NIGHT BEFORE THE MARCH, A
LOCAL SHERIFF, A MEAN MAN,
REALLY JUST MEAN,
HE CARRIED AN
ELECTRIC COW PRODER.
AND HE DIDN'T USE IT ON COWS.
HE USED IT ON PEOPLE.
HE WOULD PUSH PEOPLE.
HE WOULD BEAT PEOPLE.
FOR EXERCISING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
SO ON THAT
BRIDGE ON SUNDAY ALABAMA STATE
TROOPERS, WE CONTINUED TO WALK.
WE CAME WITHIN HEARING DISTANCE.
A MAN SPOKE UP AND SAID I'M
MAJOR JOHN CLOUD, ALABAMA STATE
TROOPERS.
THIS IS AN UNLAWFUL MARCH, YOU
WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE.
I GIVE YOU THREE MINUTES TO
DISPERSE AND RETURN TO YOUR HOME
HOMES OR TO YOUR CHURCH.
AND THE YOUNG MAN WALKING BESIDE
ME, ONE OF THE LEADERS, IN DR.
DR. KING'S ORGANIZATION BY THE
NAME OF JOSE WILLIAMS.
SAID MAJOR, GIVE US A MOMENT TO
KNEE AND PRAY.
MAJOR, MAY I HAVE A WORD?
ME SAID THERE WILL BE FOE WORD.
THEY CAME BEATING US WITH NIGHT
STICKS, TRAMPLEING US WITH HORSE
S
HORSES, RELEASING TEAR GAS.
I WAS ADMIT IN THE HEAD BY A
STATE TROOPER WITH NIGHT STICKS.
I THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO DIE ON
THAT BRIDGE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS THE LAST
NONVIOLENT PROTESTS.
AND ALL THESE MANY YEARS LATER,
I DON'T RECALL HOW I MADE IT
BACK UP ACROSS THE BRIDGE TO THE
BUT I REMEMBER BEING IN THE
CHURCH, AND SOMEONE ASKED ME TO
SAY SOMETHING, AND I STOOD UP
AND SAID SOMETHING LIKE, I DON'T
HOW PRESIDENT JOHNSON CAN SEND
TROOPS  TO VIETNAM.
BUT CANNOT SEND TROOPS  TO SELMA
SELMA, ALABAMA, WHOSE ONLY
DESIRE IS TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
THE NEXT THING I KNEW, THERE ARE
WHO WAS
TRANSFERRED TO A LOCAL HOSPITAL
WHERE A GROUP OF NUNS TOOK CARE
OF US.
AND LAST BEFORE THE ELECTION,
LATE LAST OCTOBER, I WENT TO
ROCHESTER, NEW YORK TO CAMPAIGN
FOR ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES  IN NEW
THEY TOOK ME TO THE OTHER HOUSE
THERE, WHERE SOME OF THE NUNS
ARE RETIRED AND I SAW THE STAIN
GLASS WINDOW THAT HAD BEEN IN
THIS HOSPITAL IN ROCHESTER, NEW
YORK AND SOME OF THE NUNS THAT
TOOK CARE OF ME, THAT WAS THERE,
THAT REMEMBERED ME, THEY STARTED
SAYING JOHN, JOHN, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
AND WE ALL CRIED TOGETHER.
KOJO NNAMDI:  WHAT STRUCK ME IS
HOW JOHN LEWIS AND OTHERS
TRAINED THEMSELVESES  TO
THEMSELVES FOR NON
NONRESPONSE TO VIOLENCE IN SOME
OF THE MOST ATTACKS.
HOW DID THAT STRIKE YOU?
ANDREW AYDIN:  IT FELT LIKE THE
MOST IMPORTANT FACT TO POSSIBLY
CONVEY.
I THINK MANY OF US UNDERSTAND
THE BROAD STROKES OF CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE.
MAYBE WE HAVE READ THE ROW, OR
EMERSON.
BUT REALLY, THE SELF-CONTROL IT
TAKES TO BE A SUCCESSFUL PRO
AS YOU READ THESE TEXTS, AS YOU
READ THE ACTS, THE DEFINING
CHARACTERISTIC OF THE SUCCESSFUL
PROTEST IS HOW ORDERLY AND
DISCIPLINED THEY WERE.
SO FOR US, SHOWING THAT
DISCIPLINE IS PART OF THE VISUAL
MORE SUCCESSFUL IN THE VISUAL
MEDIUM.
SHOWING THAT DISCIPLINE.
NOT JUST TELL SHOWING HOW MUCH
DO THEY HAVE TO ENDURE.
WHETHER IT'S THE CIGARETTES IN
YOUR HAIR, THE HOT COFFEE BEING
POURED DOWN YOUR BACK.
HAVING YOUR FRIENDS CALL YOU
NAMES.
IT WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
WE COULD CONVEY
.
KOJO NNAMDI:  ANY OTHER QUESTION
QUESTIONS  FROM STUDENTS HERE?
RIGHT HERE.
>> SPEAKER: THIS QUESTION IS FOR
BOTH OF YOU ALL.
DO YOU SEE SIMILARITYIES  IN
TODAY'S ACTIONS BY THE PROTESTS
?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  I SEE TODAY,
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, IN
WASHINGTON, IN ATLANTA, AROUND
THE NATION, AROUND THE WORLD
FEDERATION.
IF WE'RE USING AT THIS TIME SAME
TECHNIQUES AND TACTICS, SOME OF
THEM USE IT A LITTLE MORE UPBEAT
UPBEAT.
ANDREW WILL TELL YOU, THE
RESEARCH, MUSIC IS VERY, VERY
POWERFUL.
I SAID ON OCCASION, IF IT HADN'T
BEEN FOR THE MUSIC, THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WOULD OF COURSE
LIKE A BIRD WITHOUT WINGS.
IT BROUGHT US TOGETHER.
IT CREATED A SENSE OF FAMILY, A
SENSE OF SOLIDARITY THAT WE'RE
ALL IN THIS THING TOGETHER.
AND SOMETIMES DURING THE FREEDOM
WE WERE ARREST
ARRESTED  IN JACKSON,
MISSISSIPPI, LATER, KEPT COMING.
WE FILLED THE COUNTY JAIL, THEN
THEY TOOK US TO THE HEART OF THE
DELTA TO A PURCHASE PEOPLE WOULD
SAY, THE GUARDS, THE JAILERS
WOULD SAY, DON'T STOP SINGING
THOSE SONGS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOUR
MATTRESS AND PEOPLE WOULD MAKE
UP SONGS.
ANDREW WAS SINGING ONE OF THEM.
ANDREW AYDIN:  [LAUGHING] SO LOW
LOW, YOU CAN'T HEAR ME.
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  TODAY, YOU
SEE PEOPLE COMING IN TO GATHER
IN AN ORDERLY, PEACEFUL,
NONVIOLENT FASHION.
I WAS SO PROUD TO MARCH WITH THE
63,000 PEOPLE SHOWED UP AND
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS FROM
ATLANTA CAME TO WASHINGTON.
PEOPLE SHOWED UP AT THE AIRPORT
IN ORDERLY, PEACEFUL, NONVIOLENT
FASHION.
THEY LEARNED THEY'RE STEADY IN
THE MOVEMENT.
IT'S VERY SIMILAR.
ANDREW, I KNOW YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO ADD.
ANDREW AYDIN:  L I'M NOT GOING
TO SING.
BUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BEING IN
THE CLIMATE, CREATING THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR CHANGE TO HAPPEN
POP CULTURE.
I THINK IT'S A DAY DAY AND AGE
WE
HAVE TO LOOK BEYOND
FOR THE
FACTORS.
THEY PLAY A ROLE, BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, IT'S PEOPLE OF
CONSCIOUS, COMING TOGETHER FOR A
I'M GOING TO BLOW YA'LL'S
SPEAKERS AT THIS RATE.
I MARCHED DURING D.C. AND I'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING QUITE LIKE
IT.
[MICROPHONE FEEDBACK]
I WALKED THROUGH THE CROWDS  AND
IT WAS PEACEFUL AND IT WAS
OPTIMISTIC.
BUT THE SENSE OF REVOLUTION
WASN'T -- IN 2009, WE THOUGHT WE
RIGHT?
AND THAT'S WHY 2010 HAPPENED,
THAT'S WHAT STARTED THIS TUMBLE.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED THE WOMEN'S
MARCH, WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE
SPACE WEEKS SINCE THEN.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT OPTIMISM.
IT'S ABOUT A SENSE OF DUTY THATS
THAT
WE ALL RECOGNIZE.
MAYBE WE DEPARTMENT AS MUCH AS
WE SHOULD HAVE BEFOREHAND B. WE
ALL SAY WITH A COLLECTIVE VOICE
THAT STARTS NOW.
WE ALL HAVE SOMETHING TO
CONTRIBUTE AND WE ALL WILL
CREDIBILITY.
I THINK THAT VERY MUCH PERMIT
AITEED THAT SAME FEELING MAYBE
IN
THE LATTER DAYS T GOT LOST IN
THE FREEDOMS,ENING LIKE THAT.
THAT SENSE THAT WE ALL HAVE
SOMETHING TO CONTRIBUTE.
AND THAT WE WILL RAGE AGAINST IN
INJUSTICE TOGETHER
THE MOST
POWERFUL DEVELOPMENT IN MY OWN
LIFE THAT I'VE EVER WITNESSED
IN SOCIETY AND I HOPE YOU'RE
PREPARED BECAUSE WE NEED YOU
NEXT.
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO BE EASY, I
SPENT MOST OF THE TIME BEING
AFRAID.
AND THE CONGRESSMAN TELLING ME,
NO, NO.
THE BEST IS YET TO COME.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF WE WOULD FINISH
ANY GOOD GOOD, I DIDN'T KNOW IF
I WOULD DO A GOOD ENOUGH JOB
HONORING THE CONGRESSMAN'S STORY
STORY.
THAT WAS JUST ONE SMALL PIECE.
SO IT'S OKAY FOR YOU TO BE
AFRAID.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO BE HOPEFUL AND
THE PROGRESS OF THIS COUNTRY IS
ON YOUR SHOULDERS INCOME.
MY JENNATION, YOUR GENERATION,
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
RIGHT NOW BUT WE FEED YOU.
KOJO NNAMDI:  ANYONE ELSE?
WE HAVE TIME FOR ONE MORE
QUESTION.
AND THERE ARE FOUR HANDS RAISED.
>> SPEAKER: HI, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT CAME OUT OF THE MARCH
MARCH?
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS:  BECAUSE OF
THE MARCH, BECAUSE OF THE MARCH
-- EXCUSE ME.
I'VE BEEN TALKING TOO MUCH.  I'M
I WAS IN A COMMIT MEETING TODAY
K I HAD TO HOLLA A LITTLE.
I HAD TO PREACHALLY.
[LAUGHTER]
THANK YOU.
THE MARCH FROM SELMA TO MONTH
GENTLEMAN G.O.P. FREE, GAVE US
THE VOTING
ACTS RIGHT.
IT EDUCATED, IT INSPIRED SO MANY
TO
CONGRESS TO, PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WE NEED TO PASS A
VOTER RIGHTS ACT.
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
SUNDAY, MARCH 7, THE PRESIDENT,
THE UNITED STATES, PRESIDENT
JOHNSON CAME AND SPOKE TO JEFF
SESSIONS OF THE CONGRESS AND
INTRODUCED A BILL.
WE COMPLETED THE MARCH, AND ON
AUGUST 6, 1965, THE SO THEING
ACTS RIGHT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WERE
REGISTERED TO VOTE FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
IF IT HAD INN BEEN FOR THE VOTER
PRESIDENT CARTER OR PRESIDENT
CLINTON OR PRESIDENT OBAMA WOULD
AND I PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE IN
CONGRESS AND MANY OTHER LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS, BLACK, WHITE,
LATINOS, ASIAN-AMERICAN
, WOULD
WOULDN'T BE IN THE CONGRESS.
WE STILL HAVE A DISTANCE TO GO.
THE SUPREME COURT ALMOST
DESTROYED THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
TWO YEARS AGO.
SO WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO.
KOJO NNAMDI:  IT REST ON THE
SHOWEREDS OF YOUR GENERATION.
I'M AFRAID THAT'S ALL THE TIME
WE HAVE BUT THANK YOU TO THE
ENTIRE TEAM HERE AT THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS YOUNG READERS CENTER
CENTER.
[APPLAUSE]
.
LI LIBRARIAN OF CONGRESS CARLA
HAYDEN
.
[APPLAUSE].
THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY IN D.C.
FOR BRINGING IN THIS WONDERFUL
AUDIENCE AND FOR SENDING THEM
HOME WITH COPIES OF THE BOOK.
AND LAST, BUT OBVIOUSLY, NOT
LEAST, THANKS  TO ANDREW AYDIN
AND CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS FOR
SHARING THEIR STORIES.
[APPLAUSE]
.
I'LL CLOSE WITH THE WORDS
RELATIVE OBSCURITY
, DISCOVER
INFORMATION AND EITHER FULFILL
IT OR BETRAY IT.
GO FORTH AND FULFILL YOUR
MISSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
[APPLAUSE].